une répétition à la saveur particulière
les 25 et 26 mai dernier la troupe jouer
double jeu et sur scène un comédien que
le public a peu l'habitude de voir dans
ce rôle quand vous allez vendre vos
actions
vincent besson le directeur du théâtre
espace coluche de plaisir j'ai jamais
pensé une seconde déjà de remonter sur
scène j'avais pas du tout l'idée que je
le ferai il a fallu qu'elle soit le
metteur en scène vincent rouvet qui me
demande de le faire alors de me
retrouver ici à jouer ici jamais j'ai
imaginé une seconde on n'a pas toujours
s'acheter des partenaires il est très
franc du regard il est il joue avec avec
ses partenaires il les écoute
voilà c'est très agréable vincent
desmans a dirigé la salle pendant dix
ans il prend sa retraite à l'issue de la
saison arrivé le 1er avril 2009 après
plusieurs années comme directeur des
affaires culturelles de provins de
travailler avec la personne qui était
l'adjointe à la culture à l'époque qui
est madame le maire aujourd'hui qui m'a
tout de suite blessé il ya une espèce de
confiance qui s'est installée donc j'ai
une grande liberté de programmation et
ça c'est ça j'ai jamais connu ça nulle
part je peux dire mot triste quand même
parce que ça fait dix ans dix ans c'est
pas mal dans une vie de collaboration
aussi intense avec une complicité forte
très importante une confiance si total
mais nous nous avions je dirais là mais
l'autre des goûts assez commun et puis
on a partagé des moments très très fort
à la fois joyeux et moins joyeux donc
c'est plus qu'un agent qui savent qu'ils
sont vastes et sa partenaire c'est un
artiste si depuis deux ans vincent
desmons remonte sur scène après dix sept
ans d'arrêt une passion commencé au
début de sa vie d'adulte
loin de sa première envie celle de
devenir avocat à l'époque j'ai fait mon
service militaire et j'ai fait
connaissance d'un garçon à l'armée
qu'est devenu mon meilleur ami depuis et
il m'a fait intégrer une troupe de
théâtre amateur
du coup j'ai enchaîné sur un cours de
comédie chez jean laurent cochet où j'ai
appris énormément de choses
ils s'occupent très vite de sa première
salle à draveil le théâtre donald
cardwell le costumier américain et même
celui qui fera remonter vincent sur
scène à la fin de draveil j'ai de
nouveau oublier ça et puis j'ai
rencontré
un jeune metteur en scène qui s'appelle
vincent rouvet qui est un des co
directeurs du théâtre darius milhaud à
paris et qui m'a dit mais as-tu va
bientôt être à la retraite il a eu là
une phrase double que j'aime beaucoup il
m'a dit tu sais qu'il ya plein de rôles
de vieux ou théâtre la page plaisir à se
tourner pour vincent desmons pour
retrouver son nom dans une programmation
il faudra dorénavant regarder du côté
des distributions